you Australia off of scram are you like
what are what are our worst anime takes
what's got to be the hottest take they
got the community [ __ ] up in arms and
mad I in recent memory if you watched 86
yeah I actually like the 86 I I haven't
finished it but I've been trying I
thought it was so [ __ ] boring and I
said that on the podcast people lost it
they were like what do you mean I just
thought it was so slow that it was
preachy and I was like I don't care I'm
I'm just over it since it's been judging
me yeah I don't mind people who like
things I don't like or just like things
they do like I handle it like an adult
if only everyone in the anime yeah right
right I didn't even think that was a big
hot take though people got really I
remember people were really annoyed not
as hard
yeah uh you know juicy yeah I thought it
was mid as [ __ ] see this is one of those
times where I can't be an adult that's
[ __ ] bad
that is just like a wrong that's just a
wrong opinion yeah this is wrong it's
good yeah like it's like how can you
watch my hero Academia and then look at
Jiu Jitsu case and be like that's okay
dude I didn't even get past season one
of my because it's so bad season six
yeah I caught up to watch season six no
same here why because apparently The
Season's gonna be really good yep
according to Margaritas they've been
saying that every season yeah every
season and I'm like bet okay Margaritas
this is your last chance if season six
isn't good I'm gonna [ __ ] drop it I
swear to God is it good I haven't I
haven't said she was season five good
I've been on tour I've been on tour mate
season five is terrible season five is
the worst season this is so funny I just
I wasn't I remember Conor and I one day
we were just like wait there's six
seasons of this year I thought it was
still like season four yeah I literally
I think I've watched I don't know what
it was one when they had like the
gentleman and the little [ __ ] that's
the gentle criminal that's season five
yeah that's I I watched up to five yep
that's season five I got there whenever
they introduced them and I'm like what
the [ __ ] is this [ __ ] it's so bad it's
so bad I was like oh we just derailed
the whole plot to have some kind of like
scooby-doo-esque side plot the whole
show is like nothing but the worst parts
of anime where they focus on like
provisional exams for licensing ring and
it's like it's crazy because like what
like three four years ago this show was
the [ __ ] yep it was I remember when
season two was a very good especially
like during the tournament Arc oh my God
it was inescapable dude every single
anime convention was everyone's
cosplaying my hair yeah yeah you
couldn't escape it and then it just fell
off a cliff season three yeah no one
spoke about it fumbled so hard because
they had like this big building like Yo
dude it shouldn't be so deep and then he
he like went halfway through the season
it was like wait what yeah I guess like
my hot take that I haven't said I guess
publicly and this was this is actually
exclusive this was actually before
cyberpunk the cyberpunk anime yeah okay
but I was like I kind of think oh I kind
of think trigger is a bit overrated okay
it's just yeah yeah this was before
cyberpunk by the way before now how do
you feel about it yeah
[ __ ] amazing amazing but it felt like
before cyberpunk it just kind of felt
like they just kind of they they knew
how they they had like really really
good branding but it felt like so so
long since at least like an absolute
Banger I I kind of get what you mean it
was good I thought DNA was so average
BNA is what I felt like it was like a
their practice for cyberpunk yeah in a
weird way did you watch DNA no I
actually didn't watch BNA I because they
like did not promote it I feel though
I've heard of it I just didn't work yeah
I thought it was I thought it was decent
it wasn't like amazing yeah that's the
thing with most trigger shows the only
trigger shows I really liked was kill
the kill and uh you look darling in the
phrase
grid man grid man you don't like
premiere I thought you think I think it
was decent but I think it was just I I
think it's just like recycling the same
formula that's the thing right I feel I
feel trigger is able to get away with a
lot of [ __ ] that I think other Studios
would not be able to get away with
because of their branding right yeah
it's just like you see something
ridiculous happen in a trigger show yeah
and you know if it was any other Studio
then people would be like what the [ __ ]
is this like why why derail itself but
if it's triggers doing it then it's like
that's just trigger being triggered if
if [ __ ] Studio bones or you first
will release Inferno cop everyone will
like [ __ ] throw hands well I swear to
God absolutely yeah because uh to those
of them watching pong please go watch it
yeah um there's uh you know because
obviously it's trigger there's like a
lolly character in it did you see this
interview that they had with one of the
it's like it was one of the cdpr people
right and they were doing a podcast
where they were they were interviewed
about something like Rebecca yeah about
Rebecca yeah and apparently when they
first pitched the idea of Rebecca this
is uh you know project read the light
what we don't want a lolly there's no
lollies in cyberpunk what is this can
you remove it the family tree was like
no the Lolly stays we don't do the show
I'm just like like you could you imagine
this like awkward ass like 12 meeting
people with like translators and
everything and they say hey we just can
we remove the lolly in the like memory
memory yeah they say it back and then
they're just like the Lolly stays
all right okay weird all right but I
almost think that like yeah like you
said trigger was kind of I felt like the
shows weren't that good and I I almost
wonder if maybe because they had to
collaborate a bit and kind of had to
work with uh maybe some outside uh
influence that maybe it kind of you know
maybe a bit of restriction sometimes
make a better product no I I really
that's why I think cyberpunk was so good
it's good like well I think working with
CD projekt Red they've really like
reeled them in so they had something
more creative yeah so I was like yo what
the [ __ ] is this [ __ ] now get rid of
that no you the girls cannot be wearing
no clothes at all come on yeah because I
think I think seeing them really
experiment with like the you know hyper
violence and the gore was just like so
[ __ ] good and so I mean it was like a
throwback to like the old like
production IG [ __ ] right yeah yeah right
because like I I feel like when trigger
became trigger that's when they kind of
like tone down on like the adult themes
and stuff like obviously I've been
killed a kill right yeah it's like after
killer kill everyone was if anything was
kind of like okay yeah this is like it's
pretty toned down it was all right I
didn't think it was like gray but it was
all right yeah I'm curious she wanted to
give uh Sarah Punk on your moisture
media I gave it a 90.
yeah the first opening if you haven't
watched it the first opening scene is so
goddamn good oh yeah yeah and like the
moment that first scene played I was
like oh [ __ ] this is going to be
something [ __ ] special oh it was it
was it was episode oh that was good as
well episode six is a mask it might be
one of my favorite episodes of anime
ever it's so good have you ever seen the
new chainsaw man anime yeah yep I
watched episode one it was good it was
good what do you think of the did you
come in your pants it was a [ __ ] in your
pants good though it was very good there
was no no soiled trousers but it was
good this is what I said yeah right it's
it's a first episode yeah like it it did
what it needs to do I don't think
everyone made it seem like it was the
second coming of Jesus Christ came down
to bless us with some anime waifus and
chainsaws and it was just like all right
you know they hyped with all the
animation and the budget or whatever the
phone or whatever they want to call it
yeah I shouldn't say budget I got in
trouble last time I said that oh that
was that was a that was an anime
do you ever see that no when I said that
you know Demon Slayer
um I've grown attention now when I the
Demon Slayer last season came out
and the last fight was insane did you
see it like the animation was just yeah
I tweeted out being like dude this
budget is nuts and then it unraveled
into this whole thing where like a
certain few people were like yo what the
[ __ ] you you can't call it budget it's
it's not about the budget it's about the
individual animators that work on it is
spreading misinformation and then I
didn't say anything and I just kind of
left you I was like oh whatever you know
I'm not getting involved yeah and then
like uh apparently somebody one of the
guys who was tweeting about it some
people tweeted back at him being like yo
is it this is a joke chill out yeah and
apparently it all unraveled and they
claimed they got swatted and stuff and
it over you just saying the budget yeah
like the next day I woke up people were
like this is unacceptable he needs to
address this I'm like I just said that
they had a budget
what the [ __ ] happened I was just like
what what that was just sorry surreal it
was so bizarre I had to make a trip I
had to make a twit longer being like hey
guys it was a joke uh please don't
forget crazy it's anime can we all chill
the [ __ ] out right you're lucky that
those are just the anime fans could you
imagine if Demon Slayer was a
live-action TV series
but it was just so like what like you
look at it you're like this is the most
Twitter moment ever yeah
like certain groups they work each other
up and then they're just out for blood
and they get a little bit and they're
like yo this is it this is it yeah
yeah and it's like okay there was an
agenda here and it was just like weird
you know I was like I don't know what I
did or what happened and this is weird I
don't know yeah Twitter's assessment
yeah but you got to be on it right like
you have no choice I'm always on it just
because that's how I get like all the
updates to [ __ ] and find things it's
like it's just such a quick source of
information I mean if you want to stay
up to date with like drama or Internet
news yeah oh yeah you got to be on
Twitter yeah absolutely God remember the
times where you saw a twit longer and
you didn't assume someone was getting
like canceled or apologizing holy [ __ ]
this is a long explanation yeah
sure